[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission Ça ne sa
découverte alors allons-nous
[Musique]
parle pas moins alors
osam
de Salazie plus précisément à l'illette
avidote et nous nous ça va
jusqu'au sommet du Piton d'enchin
apparemment là où on en est gayaz
histoire et ben plutôt danger par là et
ben nous ça va aller allons-nous
comment allez-vous bien très bien ça va
bien bonjour madame alors dites moi je
vois que vous remonter vous arrivez d'où
comme ça voilà on a fait une petite
balade on est descendu jusqu'à la
passerelle et puis après on est remonté
le sentier qui est en face là il y a une
rivière qui est juste en dessous avec
des gros rochers c'est un très très
belle endroit magnifique et là vous avez
fait une randonnée où c'était juste
comme ça pour vous promener ah c'est
juste comme ça pour nous promener on est
on est restés là ça fait peut-être trois
quarts d'heure qu'on est là d'accord du
coup vous avez pas été sur le tuto dans
chaque et tout là-haut ah non non non
non non non non et puis non on se dit
qu'il y a il y a peut-être d'autres
choses plus accessibles pour nous donc
on va aller se balader voir les cascades
on va on va revoir les cascades on
repartant c'est un beau programme
et ben bonne continuation bonne journée
bye bye
alors
à la passerelle donc nous ça va python
ôtez le temps il menace un peu myspecte
comme ça arrive on les barres l'appli
est au moins à part par contre le
monsieur là
pareil pour garder un affaire bonjour
monsieur bonjour ça va bien bien
vous-même alors dites-moi là je vois que
vous avez des jumelles oui et à côté
vous avez comment s'appelle ça c'est une
longue vue c'est pour observer observer
les
oiseaux et c'est quoi comme oiseau là
principalement le le papa ping
d'accord et le Papon c'est c'est pas
c'est quoi comme des oiseaux ça le papa
c'est le un rapace et surtout le dernier
appât sans démitnisher de la Réunion et
quand observe un a que ça on garde en
général
je regardais essentiellement le plumage
savoir si c'est des jeunes ou des
adultes et des femelles ou des mâles
alors est-ce que la réunion n'a pas bon
P les espèces ah oui oui clairement oui
de fortes responsabilités de
conservation des espèces endémiques à la
Réunion les vrais et nous on a ne
conviennent pas à la Réunion à peu près
250 couples d'accord et c'est en
évolution mais en diminution c'est en
diminution depuis les 20 dernières
années à cause à cause principalement du
ratisside qui sont mis dans les champs
les rames mangent leur ratissides et le
papa mange le rends empoisonne d'accord
et du coup est-ce que la solution pour
ça vous ne pas panda c'est de travailler
directement avec les avec les
agriculteurs pour essayer de trouver des
méthodes alternatives aux racines
nous dit que le parfum est-ce que vous
connaissez est-ce que les vrais hommes
vis-à-vis de Eva et hanchant la légende
les vrais d'accord bon ben merci bien en
tout cas merci beaucoup bonne
continuation allez bye et bon en tout
cas mettez bien intéressant et ben moi
nous ça a continué par la puissance
allons-nous comment
[Musique]
retrouve mon moment rien que la même mot
qui a des danses derrière
la montagne ni un soleil à cross fait
pipi comme si la nature déconnait à la
la paradis pour nous rester
ait
comment il était
comment ça se fait la santé
[Rires]
un petit peu brouillard tu vois pas trop
rien mais on ressent des choses quand
même par rapport à ce qu'elle a été
vécue là-bas par rapport à un Eva
c'est ça sonne quand même pas mal
franchement enfin moi personnellement on
y croit que lui aussi pareil nous tu
veux montres là pour ça exactement
du coup voilà elle est quand même
historique emblématique de montagne est
là il fallait faire ça un moment donné
dans sa vie en terme de randonnée est-ce
qu'on va descendre
et il pense que tout le monde peut faire
mais à son rythme oui il faut avoir
quand même un petit peu de cardio quand
même un petit peu cardio parce que à
cause c'est un randonnée
[Rires]
et ben voilà au bout de deux heures et
demi de marche gars ça mêlé suis-le
piton d'enchin 1350 mètres d'altitude
bon comme dit bonne Marmagne a trouvé
tout à l'heure la montée
bonjour monsieur bonjour comment
allez-vous
un petit peu dégagé quand même loin
quelques villages de Salazie quand même
est-ce que vous connais un peu ces
histoires là puis on enchaîne alors
d'après ce que mikoni c'est un c'est un
esclave que la fuite son maître et il a
suive l'arrivée du Mans jusqu'à trouver
un python et au fait il a vécu au fait
caché dans dans cette montagne là
pendant une vingtaine d'années on en a
des des comptes on en a des poèmes que
que les nez de cette histoire là et donc
là les gens ce serait
ce serait que belila Lila était tué dans
sur le piton de hanche et que Lila
transforme à Lyon Papang il est parti
retrouve sa femme Eva d'un corps c'est
bon en tout cas les histoires les gars
bonne continuation à vous merci au
revoir
et pour ça on nous a prochain épisode de
l'émission à nous nous sera du côté de
la planète Kaf pas trop loin volcan Gaïa
semaine
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]